straight ahead on lawn crime daily
johnny depp reaches a settlement with a
one-time crew member who said the actor
got physical on set and it was a
nationwide scheme that defrauded elderly
and vulnerable people out of millions
real housewives of salt lake city star
jennifer shaw pleads guilty to
defrauding hundreds plus did you have
any involvement in heather frank's death
no kevin eastman faces trial for a
double homicide in colorado but the
defense points the finger at a different
suspect and later months after he defies
a subpoena to appear steve bannon's
contempt of court trial will soon begin
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to long crime daily i'm
your host brian buckmeyer atron was
scheduled to start in los angeles this
month where johnny depp was going to
defend himself against allegations he
assaulted a member of a crew on a film
set but now the case has been settled
lawn crimes anjanet levy is here with
the details
brian you know there were some rumblings
in the last few weeks that this case
could possibly settle so this isn't a
complete surprise rocky brooks had
accused johnny depp of assaulting him on
the set of a film back in 2017 when they
were both working together now that film
was shot in los angeles and it was city
of lies it told the story of a detective
trying to solve the murders of tupac
shakur and the notorious b.i.g
brooks claimed in a lawsuit that he told
depp they had to stop filming one night
because a permit had expired for that
area
and that depp then punched him twice in
the ribs and offered brooks 100 000 to
punch him in the face
later that night though brooks and depp
took a photo together it was a cell
phone photo but a woman working on the
set submitted a declaration to the court
saying this wasn't true at least
brooks's account wasn't and that brooks
had become belligerent with a homeless
woman and that depp told brooks to stop
yelling at her emma danoff wrote that
she had timestamped photos of the
encounter that disputed brooks's account
now the terms of the settlement are
confidential so we may never know
exactly how much debt paid if anything
and at this point in time it doesn't
appear that either side is commenting
thanks angenette joining us today is
criminal defense attorney bernardo
violona co-host terry austin and
anjanette levy bernardo with such
powerful evidence an eyewitness time
stamped photos why do you think um
or do you think sorry it would be
smarter for dept to have gone to trial
no not at all i think it was smart for
him to actually settle because at least
when you settle you know for a fact
what's going to happen and what the
dollar amount is going to be aside from
that you don't want that negative
publicity because even though you were
successful against amber heard who's to
say that you're going to be successful
this time around and we already know how
much publicity you got around the amber
herd allegations so you don't want to
repeat that now let's just put
everything to rest and just move on with
our lives and i think that's what johnny
depp wanted to do in this case yeah
terry and will the settlement ever be
known how and why are these amounts
secret
you know we may never know the exact
amount of the settlement often these
types of settlements are confidential
and that's to the benefit of both
parties you neither want to deny nor
admit anything and disclosing the amount
could actually lead people to jump to
the wrong conclusion so for instance if
it's a very low amount they could jump
to the conclusion that nothing happened
that the defendant was innocent if it's
a higher amount they could jump to the
conclusion that the plaintiff was
absolutely correct so we don't know
either one of those things you don't
want anyone to jump to any sort of
conclusions that might not be factual
all right we'll keep our feet on the
ground with this one no jump into
conclusions and jeanette why do you
think the case was settled
well i think there could be any number
of reasons brian sometimes it's cheaper
to just write a check than to pay a lot
of money for legal fees and to go to
trial sometimes that costs a lot more
and keep in mind johnny depp is touring
right now in europe with jeff beck
they've been on tour
since the end to the very end of the
defamation trial that johnny depp was
involved in with his ex-wife so he's got
work obligations he's going to start
shooting a film later this summer in
france so coming back over here to the
united states for three days
for a trial just may not have been worth
it you know of course he still has to
pay his lawyers from his other
defamation trial and that's not expected
that amber is going to be paying that 15
million or whatever it is when you
deduct the caps anytime soon so maybe
it's smarter for him to resolve this
case and move on with his tour thanks
everyone and thank you man jeanette for
the input also in california olympic
medalist kim glass is physically
assaulted and nearly blinded when a man
attacks her outside an la restaurant
the volleyball player first shared the
story via social media saying the man
who appeared to be homeless threw a
metal object at her which she believed
was a pipe as a result her eye socket
was fractured glass says she noticed the
man across the street before he threw an
object at her after that she and several
people nearby held the man down until
police arrived the 51 year old suspect
was taken to jail and booked on
suspicion of assault with a deadly
weapon right now he's being held without
bail
glass recounted the incident on her
instagram story
he had something in his hand on he was
other side of the car
in the street
and he just like looked at me with some
pretty
hateful eyes
and as i turned to go tell my friend
i think something's like wrong with him
and i think he's going to hit a car
before i knew it a big
metal bolt
like pipe hit me
right here here i just it happened so
fast he literally flung it from the
street so he was not even close to me at
all
um
kind of took me down and now you know
right now looks like my vision will be
okay and um i got really great stitching
from the doctor i have just amazing
friends of family around me and
supporting me and that's been the best
part i do have
multiple fractures up here and a small
one here but my friends have been
family amazing
still ahead on law and crime daily a
colorado man stands trial for a double
homicide but first a real housewives
reality star pleads guilty to defrauding
hundreds of vulnerable victims
[Music]
welcome back real housewives of salt
lake city reality star jennifer shaw
pleads guilty to defrauding hundreds of
victims in a telemarketing scheme
shot pled guilty on monday just one week
before her trial was expected to begin
prosecutors say shaw took part in a
nationwide scheme that largely targeted
elderly people shaw convinced the
victims she could provide financial
security and stability but instead
defrauded hundreds of people out of
their savings shaw pled guilty to one
count of conspiracy to commit wire fraud
as part of that plea agreement she will
pay six and a half million dollars in
forfeiture and could pay up to nine and
a half million dollars in restitution
sentencing guidelines show a range from
11 to 14 years behind bars but a federal
judge could hand down a heftier sentence
adam klasfeld managing editor of
lawncrime.com explains what shaw
admitted to during monday's hearing
she admitted pursuant to her plea
agreement that she
targeted that it
victimized people over the age of 55 at
least more than 10 of the victims uh
were over that age and
targeted vulnerable people according to
prosecutors as well and basically it was
built as coaching for supposed online
business of opportunities which she
admitted in court today had little or no
value uh prosecutors said that she tried
to evade law enforcement essentially by
moving the business operations from
manhattan to kosovo
so we'll
surely be learning more about it upon
her upcoming sentencing which is now
scheduled
shortly after thanksgiving we'll learn
around that time what prosecutors say
uh
they will state out the scheme in detail
but basically what we know about it is
that it was a nationwide scheme that
defrauded elderly and vulnerable people
out of millions a prosecutor said in
court that it counted uh thousands of
victims a number of which would have
testified at her trial had this gone to
a trial
okay this is a criminal case so my
question for you is could the victims of
shah uh have a civil case against her
and how likely would they win after this
guilty plea
oh they absolutely couldn't bring a
civil case and i think they would be
very likely to win particularly since
she's pled guilty she's already going to
pay 6.5 million in forfeiture and 9.5
million in restitution it remains to be
seen if the victims get any of that and
if they do any amounts they would get in
a civil action would be reduced by that
amount but she admitted that she had
these promises that she was wrong she
knew she was wrong so they could sue for
fraud they could sue for reliance upon
what she told them and you have to
believe that a jury would put themselves
in the place of these innocent victims
and they would be sympathetic to the
claims that they were defrauded so the
real question at the end of the day is
whether or not she has deep pockets
would she be able to pay anything even
if a civil suit was victorious because
we know she will be in jail probably you
know at least from 11 to 14 years and
maybe more yeah now former prosecutor in
two different states now criminal
defense attorney bernarda how does
forfeiture and restitution work in a
criminal case what if the defendant
doesn't have the money to pay
jennifer shaw she decided to mess with
the wrong person because when it comes
to the federal system first off
restitution is measured by the losses to
the victims and forfeiture is measured
by the proceeds from the crime itself
what happens well one she's facing her
sentence so as a part of her sentence
she's going to be interviewed by united
states probation officer that's going to
determine how much she has in terms of
assets how much she has in the bank how
much value does she have in terms of
does she have houses or anything to
determine what she's able to actually
pay but if she's not able to pay after a
judge has determined that this is what
you're supposed to give in restitution
or forfeiture she can face being sent
back to jail for additional time because
she failed to obey a court order so that
that's a possibility in terms of the
government getting their money you have
a feeling we're going to see a lot fewer
handbags in her possession over the next
couple of months after they're done with
her thank you for that breakdown both of
you and in california a report reveals
the state social service system failed
the turpin siblings who were rescued
from captivity in their parents home
four years ago
david and louise turpin abused their 13
children for years until 2018 when their
daughter jordan managed to escape and
tell police what was happening at home
she told officials her brothers and
sisters who range in age from 2 to 29
had been starved and sometimes chained
to their beds authorities subsequently
learned that terpins had deprived their
children of hygiene education sleep
health care and more the children were
isolated from the world some for decades
in what the media dubbed a house of
horrors david and luis are now serving a
life sentence in prison but that's not
where the abuse ended according to the
new report issued from outside
investigators some of the siblings
received poor care after entering the
foster care system even being placed
with caregivers who were later charged
with child abuse the months-long
investigation said the system was short
staffed and underfunded making it
difficult to ensure safety and care
and in cult news parole is denied for a
one-time member of the manson family who
once described himself as charlie
manson's right-hand man last week a
california panel denied parole for 79
year old bruce davis prior to this davis
was recommended for parole seven times
but was rejected each time by the then
california governors davis did not
participate in the infamous 1969 taylor
bianca murders in the hollywood hills
during which six people were killed by
manson family members in an effort to
jump start a race war instead davis took
part in the murder of donald trudy shea
a ranch hand who worked with cult
members during the late 1960s manson's
family members took up residence spawn
ranch which had previously been used as
a backdrop for western movies davis
participated in the ranch hands murder
and turned himself over to police in
1970. from here davis must wait three
more years to try parole again
coming up on law and crime daily jury
selection will soon begin in steve
bannon's contempt of court truck
plus we head to colorado for gripping
witness testimony how a man there
learned a homicide victim's body had
been found on his property
[Music]
welcome back we head now to colorado for
the double homicide trial of kevin dean
eastman as a defendant's former employer
takes the stand it was on his property
where one of the victim's bodies was
found eastman is charged with two counts
of first-degree murder tampering with a
deceased human body and tampering with
physical evidence for allegedly killing
his ex-girlfriend heather frank and her
new love interest local musician stanley
scott sessions on separate days in
february of 2020. frank and eastman both
had arrest warrants in connection to
sessions murder before frank's body was
found prosecutors say eastman slit
session's throat in frank's apartment
and that eastman fatally shot frank in
the chest twice to silence the only
witness to sessions killing hiding her
body on the property of his new employer
troy bonnell investigators say eastman
burned sessions body and was allegedly
preparing to burn frank's body when he
was arrested at a nearby gas station
bonnell spent the entire day monday on
the stand eastman's defense attorney
said bonnell's inconsistent testimony
from previous video interviews proved
his lack of credibility as a witness
they pointed a finger at him for frank's
death after prosecutors specifically
asked if he was involved
when did you first learn of heather
frank's
deceased body being found on your
property
uh
it would have been hours after i was
at the
police station
did you have any involvement in heather
frank's death no on december 29th 2020
you learned that dna your dna was found
on this rank
i was told it was found on a pack of
cigarettes
that your dna was found in a pack of
cigarettes on her deceased body
i did not hear that
and you were asked uh at that point to
explain
um
why that why that was
yeah i don't recall hearing that i i
recalled ask being asked about a pack of
cigarettes that would why how would that
of my dna be on a pack of cigarettes
that was located on this drink i did not
hear the part of where she
where she was she had a pack of
cigarettes
on this on her on a deceased body
do you think bono had anything to do
with frank's murder and do you believe
it beyond a reasonable doubt
well look i think it's a smart move for
the defense to try to point to someone
else but i don't think that it has been
shown beyond a reasonable doubt that
bonnell had anything to do with that
murder yes it was on his property and
frankly that's not a good look but i
don't think that they've discovered or
shown or demonstrated in any way shape
or form that he had anything to do
with the killing or even with the
disposal of
the body so i i think that the
defense still has a very difficult case
and and the defense is going to have a
hard time showing that kevin eastman
wasn't the one who obviously killed both
uh of the victims and tried to you know
burn both of the bodies yeah maybe he's
not the other suspect but bernardo what
do you think of the defense's argument
that bunnell isn't credible and if he's
not how does that hurt the prosecution's
case
well in terms of every witness that
testifies for the prosecution
credibility is a huge role it's a huge
factor that the jury has to determine
whether this witness is actually telling
the truth so if you're able to crack
down on a person's credibility and the
jury finds some kind of reasonable doubt
because they can't believe this witness
then guess what whether you think he did
it didn't do it or had some kind of
inclination or gut feeling they did it
it doesn't matter because you have to
prove the defendant's guilt beyond a
reasonable doubt and that piece of doubt
right there will be enough to actually
acquit it yeah it looks like the defense
is getting two bites of the apple with
this theory as to this witness we'll see
how it plays out make sure to follow the
law and cry network for gavin gavel
coverage on the kevin dean eastman case
when we come back steve bannon is headed
to trial what to expect as the former
white house chief strategist stands
trial for contempt of congress
welcome back to law and crime daily a
federal judge orders the trial of former
white house chief strategist steve
bannon to move forward on charges of
contempt of congress
bannon defied a subpoena from the
january 6th committee last year to
testify and provide documents related to
his involvement in the efforts to
overturn the 2020 election when he
didn't appear by the deadline the
justice department charged bannon with
two counts of contempt of congress
bannon made a last-minute offer this
week to testify before the committee
days ahead of his criminal trial the
offer was accompanied by a letter from
former president donald trump claiming
to waive executive privilege over
bannon's testimony a move the committee
and justice department say may not be
applicable to a former president on
monday a judge denied bannon's request
to delay the trial and ruled nearly
every proposed defense from bannon's
attorney is a relevance to the alleged
crime against him his trial is scheduled
to begin next monday
bernard is bannon choosing to testify
days before his trial on a fence he
could use against these contempt charges
and will they work
brian stephen bannon sees it that the
writing is on the wall that he's going
to be convicted so i think what he's
doing by asking to testify or agreeing
to testify at this point he wants to
mitigate his losses in the sense that
once he is convicted he wants to do in
sentences let a judge know like look i
volunteered to speak in front of the
committee i volunteered to actually talk
at this time but it's too little too
late at this point he's facing one month
up to 12 months in custody and a fine
from a hundred dollars up to a hundred
thousand dollars so we'll wait and see
what's going to happen but i think it's
too little too late yeah and tyrion this
is a little aspect that i thought was
interesting as well why do you think
bannon attached a letter from former
president donald trump waving a
privilege many argued never existed
well he's trying to say that that
privilege did exist and that trump has
the right to waive the privilege and
trump is trying to claim the same thing
but i agree with bernard she says too
little too late i say too bad so sad
bannon is definitely going to either pay
a fine or go to jail and here's why
judge nichols basically dismissed all of
his defenses he not only said you're not
going to win a motion to dismiss but he
said you have no defense of privilege he
said you have no defense that the
process didn't work right so his only
defense is going to be that it wasn't
intentional and he's not going to be
able to show that because he completely
ignored that subpoena that was issued
back in september and even if he had
just responded and said you know just
postpone that might have helped but he
didn't do it sounds like he got bad
legal advice leading evidence well
bernardo terry thank you very much and
thank you for joining us here on law in
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you